one two three it's well if yesterday was
Thursday and the day before yesterday
was Thursday then today must be Thursday
oh okay it's Friday it's Friday January
26th thanks to the george bruce branch
of the new york public library for
participating let's get right to the
survey describe a perfect day I wake up
in the morning right 4,000 words Sara
comes home from school
we have sushi dinner together and then
we read until it's time to go to bed oh
and the office is on and I watched the
office and Pam and Jim hook up yes
assuming I don't remember the words
assuming all things come to an end how
will humans go extinct pop it on with TS
Eliot on this one not with a bang but
with a whimper so how are you feeling
about kids these days I really want a
baby but where would we put one Hank
where are we gonna fit a baby inside
this apartment are we gonna put it under
the bed I wanna have a baby whatever
baby a lot babies are adorable
won't I have like 16 of them when I like
a little army of babies in this space
create your own question and answer it
puppet the question is pirates or ninjas
ninjas and just like how fast they
strike what does ambrosia taste like you
know what ambrosia tastes like it tastes
like all the things you can't eat on
Weight Watchers cheeseburgers sugar
cookies regular frickin ice cream
instead of like ice cream that's made
out of air and human hope if you were a
cliche what cliche would you be a dark
and stormy night what's your least
favorite part of any given day I don't
enjoy brushing my teeth
do you enjoy science fiction I really
like Kurt Vonnegut and I also am a big
fan of the short stories of Margo
Lanagan
cheese or chocolate why did you just
name two things I can't eat anymore
god that's so mean what was your first
concert I think it might have been the
Cure in ninth grade
with Devon razor I did like the Cure a
lot where would you live if you could
live anywhere
North Carolina would you prefer
invisibility or time travel well as you
can see I already
have the gift of invisibility I'm
wearing my invisibility cloak right now
so I guess I would choose time travel if
you could start a business that would be
instantly successful what would it be a
malaria curing business a we only sell
novels by John Green store anyway I'm
not sure what this store would sell
necessarily but it would definitely be
called the blind assassin in your pants
I'm sorry I can't stop myself thanks to
all the commenters for their great ideas
what's wrong with the world I I really
think the big problem is uh people you
know I mean puppets are a small problem
puppet I'm not going to let you guys off
the hook entirely but but people were
the worst can I put this survey on my
web page you may Hank I'll see you on
Monday